[Music]
[Music]
Oh
don't ever turn back
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
to eat defeat to the big city to be to
the hell
[Music]
B - E - B - the eat yeah get that Helen
I today's apply of the balance register
when you visit coopos.com slash horrible
that's get double dark hot sauce
[Music]
talk space talk space the online therapy
company that believes that therapy
should be affordable confident - and
convenient a talk space therapist can
put you on the path to a happier life
for a special offer for our listeners
visit talk space.com slash animal talk
space makes it easy to connect with an
experienced licensed therapist
handpicked just for you for as little as
30 mm we losing talk space you can send
your therapist text audio and video
messages whenever you want or even do a
live video chat and there's a special
offer for our listeners you can use
coupon code Hannibal to get $30 off your
first month and show your support for
this podcast that's Hannibal and talk
space.com slash Hannibal talk space
therapy for how we live today
[Music]
welcome to the handsome Rambler podcast
we are here at Bonnaroo I'm Hannibal
Buress and I am Tony trim we at
Bonneville winner goddamn makeshift tent
we are pretty much outside except for
some plastic above our heads a little
bit
we're outside it is Lively
the second day of Bonnaroo is Friday uh
Tony just got into town
I literally just flew in here like a
[ __ ] Tasmanian devil they're taking
me here taking me there I'm just like
we're just getting ready to go it was it
was it's lively I got in I got into
Nashville yesterday I made a choice to
not come to the first day of honor Oh a
choice yeah I was any area was there
anybody even good playing last night I
could show there was somebody good if
somebody that name didn't ring for me
but it's Bonnaroo it has to be somebody
good you know but nobody's name that
rang enough for me to come yeah you
can't deny the book another festival but
here's why I didn't come because I knew
that I could not handle four nights of
Bonnaroo yeah that's a good call
couldn't do it I knew it was crazy I
still went out in Nashville and kicked
it I had a good time met up with some
folks from my urban urban cowboy they
have a small kind of boutique hotel
thing Jersey oh yeah that joint we were
chilling at that one that's joke I
showed that we have to downtown yeah and
so uh hung out with them and that's what
you see that video I posted yeah the guy
getting crucified yeah what the [ __ ] was
going I was going to ask you about that
what the [ __ ] yeah it was in the bar
inside the bar all of a sudden they were
him in the person working there with
wrestling we couldn't tell you know
whether they were kidding in that and
then the guy started choking him out he
started choking out the bigger guy and
then uh
even the bartender the bartender that
was said hey are they messing around I
said I don't because he's still holding
on to that chokehold is he going blue he
wasn't going blue he was just holding it
night yeah the guy did was was wrestling
him down had some type of LM a some type
of MMA or some type of skills and so he
was holding to do you know kind of just
waiting for backup so now he's sitting
there this weird Idol minute it's a long
as minute and then eventually two other
people come help get him out and that's
when I started feeling it was so funny
seeing that image of the guy he look
like he's been cruising he look like
he's proven fact they had his are
literally one guy had his other arm the
other guy is out having a guy had him in
a full nelson and he look like Jesus on
the cross but let's talk about the
funniest part about that clip yeah cuz I
got that like it 2:00 in the morning
yeah and it's just it's like a seven
second clip at all all I hear the ladies
like she puts her hand up and she's like
can't film you're like shut up I could
film shut up I can't feel I can film and
also shut up this is a public favor part
of the thing is you just like shut up I
could film and also I was already
filming yeah um and it was a crazy
situation I didn't know at that point I
thought I didn't know she even worked at
the bar I thought she was with the guy
maybe yeah and yeah I can film that type
of thing is that I'm not that's what our
hip-hop that's what I'm for yeah and I
get a part of me in my head still though
you know I get in my head with periods
in this moment you don't like people
filming you doors but this is a guy that
he put his hands on somebody and got put
out of the bar and they put him out
pretty nicely who's the one that got put
out the one that was getting choked or
the one that was choking the one that
was choking
Wynonna to what he he tried to he put
his hands around a bouncers neck
apparently he was having some weird
stuff two girls and then the people
working their pro stuff he put his hand
around the balances neck or the person
marking their neck and then he got
hemmed up and he got put out
so that was a person I was choking them
was an employee yeah okay got you yeah
hit the story and they handle the print
days I do business everything subdue to
dude they didn't write they didn't put
hands on like three men on them right
had three dudes on it was just like one
hat each arm
they one hat each arm the other dude had
the Full Nelson and he got him up out of
there it was a visit and he thought once
they got him they just pushed them off
yeah and they left you know some you
some of these bounces in some nightclubs
they stopped [ __ ] out man I see
I've seen some terrible [ __ ] I thought
they did a master class on how to get
somebody out smoothly come back in we I
closed that spot down it was uh but yet
a girl came up and don't know filming
but nice you should want that I wanna
send I'll send them the footage so they
could send that to future employees I'd
be like this how you handle this is how
you get people out you can grab one arm
you make them like Jesus take them to
the cross grab man like take over here
look at a cross this is how you make a
man get out I need three people you need
one the whole this is the middle of the
body you need two people to hold the
arms in the wrist hold them firmly at
the wrist actually as I could ivory
watch it a few times because it was just
so perfect
yeah the way they held the wrist seemed
like a technique okay it seems like so
they had some trained fighters yeah it
seemed like in a they went so calm
afterwards I talked to I'll talk to the
guys not even right after that maybe you
know 45 minutes after that we chatted
and they didn't seem heated or anything
what if they're all what if they just
purposefully always hire martial arts
masters like one Hapkido master ones
brazilian jiu-jitsu and the other guys
is a tough guy that's on the resume is
it yeah you like you have to have some
kind of formal training or you had to
have some time in the Octagon well
that's ideal if you have somebody
dealing with drunky because this was in
a in a very nightlife heavy area of
Nashville cuz I got I got it I got a guy
in my kung fu class who makes a living
being a bouncer he's a big dude yeah but
the fact that he knows Wing Chun he gets
gigs all the time when's the last time
you've been an altercation
physical altercation cuz you you're like
uh people don't know you a high-level
martial arts but you try to keep it
low-key cuz you don't want to be into
stereotypes not just on this I mean to
some that you thought not to brag about
yeah you use it when you got to use it
right but yeah I mean it's I mean the
last altercation was in New York and
actually the irony of it all is that it
was over somebody calling me Jackie Chan
I could call you Jackie said he bumped
into me at the bar he's a watch out and
I was like bro you bumped into me and
he's like [ __ ] you Jackie Chan and then
that was it and then I just hit him
buddy
and then you I'll show you dick yeah
yeah that's why I just you hit up a
bunch of times
pop them a bunch of times and then we
ended up on the floor like wrestling
yeah but my ground games tight so I
think I would have been able to finish
him right you know by that time people
pulling each other off whatever but when
you out with a girl no I was just out
with uh I was just out with a bunch of
business business people people I do
business with yeah for the clothing
store we're all there but the world
we're all cool but we went out for
drinks after we handled business and did
like orders and [ __ ] then we ended up at
this bar in this altercation and
actually they were just like I was like
oh no I ruined that relationship but
they were like no that was cool [ __ ] you
Naaman and also we we need excitement in
our lives there are edgy friend and my
punch and [ __ ] this has some
weird [ __ ] exactly so it all worked out
wait a minute now Bonnaroo is poppin you
two is playing in the background is it
so this is such a surreal setting for
the podcast
YouTube playing in the background
there's cars and [ __ ] around us
Bonnaroo this is a fourth festival we've
done in four weekends yeah we've been
going at Moe fest Boston Colin cluster
fest and here at Bonnaroo hello to
Coachella we have some air between
Coachella Doh we did Coachella but there
was a lot of festivals man it's a lot of
that day but I'm sorry four consecutive
weeks it's been getting insane
it's that season man I feel like I'm a I
feel like I'm a rock star
I love it it's the water I've learned
I've been feeling like life I feel like
holy [ __ ] you know all rivals this [ __ ]
is so live man it's insane they got us
driving us around the golf carts in here
we made it drive around the golf carts
you know since fans got in a day yeah
I'm so jealous of that by the way but go
ahead kids has a bunch of dirt bikes
yeah
and so you know he rides out I don't
want to stay the one for show but they
after we watched friends in the light
earlier yeah
and they were kind of in the artist
compound and they want yo Hannibal I was
about to is after the show yes hey
what's up y'all and I saw the bikes and
I'd even go over I saw some of them
already and I just grabbed one of the
bikes and just never I've lived out it
was built out on the dirt bike into the
hit the back roads that has the lady
that picked me up
uh she was I was just like where's
Hannibal Hannibal on sight she's like
yeah he's fine he's just riding around
on the tiny motorcycle I was like what I
was like what yes but the first thing
that hit my mind was I better get one of
those too yeah go they got a few of them
but I drift off on it in the night I
dipped off to I went to the comedy tent
to kind of flex a little bit just by
pulled up on a motorcycle yeah it is fun
man you know it's a good just run around
the golf course fun I can't imagine
having a tiny motor so have you
tiny motorcycle it was a good strong
choice by the kid next man next year bro
I'm not a scooter something we got ask
okay see that's the thing with comedies
only spaces out at Bonnaroo what do you
mean
like they put to the other I played by
it was it no they space out the ax
oh so last time we did it was 2014 last
time before that was 2011 yeah so unless
we just come to Bonnaroo to kick it and
just bring motorcycles yeah and I mean I
guess that's not made the suspension
while you're asking that guy unless we
really I guess yeah we're going to do
this but you was really but it felt it
felt unbelievably good to ride don't
knows Daryl engine with a motorcycle a
little motorcycle you once you get
because it's kind of small until your
knees might hit the [ __ ] yeah it's a
little weird posture body situations
just having a moat once you hit it it's
good me and yeah one look on your face
no like that one 2014 when were here
I ate a bunch of mushrooms and I was not
like I was just [ __ ] waiting because
there was too much energy around and uh
Gabe a works for Red Bull scooped me up
in a golf cart and I was just riding on
the back of a golf cart and he was
driving me through the festival and that
was the most fantastic trip like it took
my mushroom trip from dark yeah hi like
immediately so I can only imagine how
much better that be if you're on a tiny
motorcycle it was it was though I wasn't
I mean I wasn't high or anything I had
one drink but just riding through you
know people see you and [ __ ] yeah not
Hannibal on a tiny bike is that time on
a tiny motorcycle and I can't even wait
because if I wave I might get a nice
bang out on that [ __ ]
I just keep riding so yeah well to
chance the rapper for letting me borrow
his tiny motorcycles Bonnaroo has a I
want to say I won't try to figure out
how to articulate this without sounding
cliche
but it has a real festival it's festive
yes out of the festivals we've been to
have been good yeah
mole Fest was great uh Boston Colin was
good yeah
plus defense was outstanding they did a
great job but Bonnaroo has a certain
energy I guess what I'm trying to say is
probably 33 percent at the lease of
people on psychedelics Oh trucks
absolutely so we have survived I think
that's probably why Coachella is a
little more tame because like by a
certain time they kick everyone out but
this [ __ ] is poppin til sunrise
right yeah with all this [ __ ] on the UH
natural schedule from 3:00 to 6:00 a.m.
yes so this is like a drug this is like
this is like a hotbed for drugs and also
they have the the one club the Christmas
dinner yes it's really cold but when
they know that people that are on drugs
aren't really hot yo that [ __ ] I walked
up into that [ __ ] when I was on shrooms
in 2014 because they added them and that
that's when I started wigging out I'm
like what the [ __ ] is happening why am I
here why you know it was go to him cuz
they were playing like the same beat
here's one of those sits well he walked
up with me right we always get a trim in
uh my my ex-girlfriends ready were there
in there too you know all tripping in
that [ __ ] that's right and they were
just playing it was one of those sits
with a know people are tripping on some
yeah and so they could tolerate the same
instrumental for ten minutes like the
same town to downtown town mm so Don's
downtown to downtown town and is this
code is [ __ ] there I [ __ ] remember
I booked that's when I separated with
y'all I booked and I'm like looking for
the trailer where we were staying at and
I remember looking to my right and
seeing the silent disco bunch of people
dancing and the lights lights and
there's no music a lot that's when I
like legit lost my [ __ ] I'm like I need
to go to the trailer when you lost just
seeing the silent disco yeah
were drawn to it no I was just like I'm
looking at that and then I'm like I'm
like where the [ __ ] am I like I couldn't
handle the trip at that point it just
got [ __ ] got too intense she got too
real so I drew so I had to go on so I
went in the trailer shut the blinds and
then I head up scuba Steve and he sent
Gabe over on the [ __ ] go-cart yeah
and then when we started riding around a
go-kart everything was good again you
know that that's where that joke came
from about me being on cuz I was on
mushrooms also yeah and for me it wasn't
a good I think of Jesus talked about
this in his stand-up - I think that
being at Bonnaroo but being on mushrooms
and being recognizable at a festival and
at a festival engine is terrifying yeah
it's horrible absolutely and so it
sounds like a good idea trip at this
festival it was a mess and then that's
where I came up with that dumps I just
said that to her yeah
where I was tripping out that thought I
was solve deep and smart and I said hey
babe isn't it crazy how some songs our
hits and some songs aren't but that
sounds like a stupid thing to say but it
is crazy right absolutely into some
songs I mean that's just how I think
when I'm high when I smoke weed and just
like what is this like how did the song
because sometimes a song hits because of
the it's a good song and then the
machine is behind it but then sometimes
you know we talked the artist with a
with their biggest hits is something
they don't even like that much or they
didn't expect or it was an accident or
they thought it was a throwaway and then
sometimes a hit is calculated we're
going to make this a hit and then
sometimes they we're gonna make this a
hit and it's not a hit we're gonna try
to make this hit this is a machine we're
gonna do this got this feature on it we
got this producer and the [ __ ] just
don't take flops no I mean it's fun
I mean in the context of what you're
saying is funny but I understood what
you were saying yeah in those in that
you're mad a few words but I understood
what you were saying I know that's like
the long-winded answer but that's what
you meant to say well no I know
wait a moment here's what I was saying
when is it crazy that some song hits and
some songs aren't yeah we were watching
Pusha T you know and his set was solid
he's a solid rapper he's great and then
it was a couple songs where people just
went crazy it was people you know
sometimes people just kind of you know
just enjoys to [ __ ] with mid-level
energy and just have an it and then some
songs come on
and people go apeshit and that's what I
was observing and it lets you out and
that's where some songs are hits some
songs are hits and some songs Wow
some songs are hit and subside I
[Applause]
so yeah I was bugging a little bit yeah
a little yeah yeah man we also have
Diplo coming on in the show uh I don't
know if he's gonna make it but you know
I'm also 105 I'm okay with that
yeah but I'm glad I think he's gonna
make I had to haul all this [ __ ]
don't leave me with dinner we got the
bottom of a disease there still is no I
don't I just got off a [ __ ] van I
haven't caught his energy oh yeah you
can try to play it right
I'm kind of trying probe I'm Tony I'm
gonna give me completely you to put the
bottle rule Wow we take it again love
drinking again and joining him to the
[ __ ] bottom room bar we kicking again
bar drinking again bar people to follow
me ridiculous long jump on the following
closet is mission impossible
Parvati get my check
me see how about now
that's better anyways yeah that's all
about cluster fest cluster first cluster
fest last week good time that [ __ ] was
crazy I mean first of all that was like
a legendary weekend for you is when you
opened up for Jerry Seinfeld and Dave
Chappelle on the same night
what yeah that's [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
crazy I couldn't believe it I was faded
yeah by the end of the night what also
earlier that we did I did the podcast
with Anna Faris honor ferrets probably
said way too much on her [ __ ] check it
out I won't tell them to cut I was I was
talking Wow oh yeah what were you saying
that was too much no I was just talking
well [ __ ] sometimes I get into you know
they caught me in that hungover mo yeah
you know sometimes when you get hung
over you really yeah and you you hung
over you you have to do something in the
morning or the early afternoon so you
kind of in a vulnerable spot solid
talking about [ __ ] so yeah she caught
you in a vulnerable state not vulnerable
but I was just like well it wasn't like
I was just talking about my
ex-girlfriends and [ __ ] it was just well
I was just talking well [ __ ] crying and
[ __ ] yeah I cry I cry but they go
through Cooper so my single Cooper
pseudo been through it out my crying
please baby you so Anna Faris podcast
then uh did the we did the show we did
our show
yeah packed out uh uh who else is an
assignment Naz was on there yeah this
mess was outstanding special no not yet
I'm gonna get out this female Gracie
when we when we when I first met him we
were in LA and he is still a new
up-and-comer
yeah and that's how I felt like it was
so close I feel like he blew up like
right after that I feel like James later
he was just on TV like he blew up fast
he's doing this he's a funny dude yeah
he's hilarious Bess is crispy yeah I got
to see it he does a lot of visual stuff
too all really and
it does like lightning SHIVs oh [ __ ]
material is great yeah the presentation
is really new and on point the camera
angles nice great good for him did his
thing it's really it was so dope and
slightly infuriating at the same time
yeah cuz you're like why didn't I think
it is first he wouldn't you know why it
was just we're yeah we're but was like
when Chris Chris Rock came backstage at
the Apollo he's like man you gonna make
me [ __ ] around get a DJ dude I was like
that's the best non-direct a compliment
that I've ever had yeah
wait was but it was so slick it looks so
great I'm genuinely like I don't say it
with any hyperbole I think as far as
presentation yeah his special is pushing
the the art of specials forward oh wow
like that's how that's a visually the
the the story and the whole [ __ ] is
great he talked about you know his high
school prominent you know being Muslim
and you know interaction with his father
but the presentation was was really
outstanding right here so everybody
check out a Assam Minaj homecoming king
on Netflix that [ __ ] is crispy and book
but anyways was I thought about um yeah
you kind of went off on her son yeah
with it I was although he was on the
show with as a cluster fest yeah yeah
yeah so yeah we did cluster fest did
gibberish rap' again had done zippers
wrapping a while ballerinas on point but
the festival itself huge crowds
everything was packed everything ran
smoothly first year festival in a minute
I might wanna I'm not trying to suck up
to get booked again it genuinely was a a
good experience yeah it was [ __ ] was
just moving they they treated as well at
good food
and and the drinks is right and you know
they your friends get big get back
without any trouble in the beginning it
was a little tight for me but other than
other than a couple of hiccups in the
beginning it was it was pretty smoothest
as soon as you got out of sight because
sometimes you send me on site before you
get there yeah and I say I wasn't me I
never just like get the [ __ ] no you're
not Hannibal and you don't have no
credit credentials or yes another age
having a backpack trying to get in well
because we chaos man I gotta tell you I
mean you know you're my friend and I got
to see you know you saw what happened at
the beginning an animal furnace yeah
yeah what it do didn't even know I was
trapped in there but one you saw that
[ __ ] with a guy that knows me and I was
coming to my own [ __ ] yeah so now I got
a I can't show up cold cuz I gotta see
what the temperature is and you you tell
me you like your day on some [ __ ]
the light news weird the audio to Tony
will tell me he'll be like Yoda audio do
decide do it on the sound obviously a
failed musician he's very better being
weird I'm giving him simple direction
and he's not wanting to take it is he's
being very difficult and the lifestyle
being weird is just you know we just got
simple stuff and so then I kind of
notice vibe when I get there it's so
true I give you like every tiny detail
used to be that holy Samoas a until now
he does this and he's bitter and he
hates em ya know that you got me to a
tee right there in that one but uh but
yeah cross defense was fun so yeah that
did a bit about five performances that
night so did the on affairs podcast did
my show popped up on stage during W
kamau Bell and re are Kondabolu
Kondabolu Kondabolu Wow he's gone he's
gonna hear this or hear about this he's
gonna hear about this and Kondabolu
Kondabolu ah
called the bone I gotta I'm not
contributing this one we're born Aurora
didn't mean to mess up your name popped
up doing their podcast me and come out
wearing the same pair of me undies
shoutouts we wear the same pair because
honey's very limited edition [ __ ] does
feel good my one of my agents Brittany
Meyers hit me too that you know cuz I
guess she was staying at come out ass
and and I think for some reason I pulled
my shirt up at some point and she said
you know come I have all the same
underwear nothing for real that's
[ __ ] crazy me undies me undies middle
DS London that was great because I me
and me and W Kamal actually uh which we
trained under the same kung-fu teacher
that I trained under now what's that I'm
irritated Phillip nearing he teaches it
man it Mon doing well son yeah yeah so
he learned under the same guy when when
he was living in Chicago cuz yeah he
went to the University of Chicago he was
on fall you was on the third I was on
the third and so after set it's like I
immediately brought him backstage and we
we were doing this thing called cheese
sauce sticky hands yeah this is
basically right in between sparring and
like static shot shadow box shadow boxes
so it's like it's um it's a practice in
like reflexes
yeah sure like that and that was really
fun because you know you never meet
someone that knows cheese now especially
from your own teacher so it's like it's
like you're you're fighting yourself
yeah it was very interesting to watch
you guys go back and forth with yeah
yeah it was yeah that was that was like
the highlight of my cluster fest
experience Kamado he don't come off as
the type of person that will beat you up
kamal could do some damage commander
losin bed because he knows how to do the
one inch punch for sure yeah and a guy
that size doing the one inch punch on
you that's like
a regular hook for a normal dude yeah
yeah Wow
so come on Belka if you piss them off
and he came at you with some cane
punches you're in some trouble
oh man got out sighs he smashing yo yeah
it was a fun fest Wow the podcast didn't
8th Jerry Seinfeld asked me that I mean
it wasn't last milk then yeah I did a
set with Jerry Jerry Seinfeld which is
crazy bananas he asked you he like how
did this come about his folks we I mean
he is at ICM and so the ICM falls resale
what specific do you know what
specifically like whoa why exactly
specifically you got that gig like you
good because I seem such a is it because
it's such a juxtaposition between yours
and Jerry's file I don't know I think
maybe because he's no I I don't know
maybe he's like my stuff or I don't know
cuz even he was making the same joke
he's like I bet you're wondering why
you're here yeah I am Jerry I am
wondering why I'm here this combo is a
weird time it's oh yeah that was why
would I mean I would never even even
during like your peak or why you're
doing well I would never think yeah
animal one day he's gonna vote for Jerry
Seinfeld it sounds like you I mean I've
done it so Louie uh yeah Bernardo
legends if Burke uh you know s'appelle
Chris Rock is right yeah Gaffigan
actually don't I want Africans requested
a couple times Dimitri I used to work
with the Litro train but that make sense
these that makes it Dimitri makes sense
because you guys kind of that dry wit
humor arm Gaffigan makes sense I could
see you guys crossing over but Jerry
Seinfeld is just he's a very specific I
feel like comics so it's just like
finding the opener for Jerry Seinfeld
how did they settle on you because well
my question is because it's just or
anybody like who who who do you would
you say would be the perfect open after
Jerry Seinfeld
I don't the perfect one is
I don't know times mean enough of his
soul mood to see what the vibe and I'm
sure that Jerry is so proud that he can
I know Ryan Hamilton opens one sometimes
yeah
Mormon guy from he's from Idaho he plays
the seller super solid yeah yeah honey
yeah I've heard work with him sometimes
minimal ah who else
Tom Tom papa Oh God Papa works with
Seinfeld a lot I think maybe he was just
is a festival and you know this dude's
here so let's see maybe he really
enjoyed you guys his impression of him
on the Eric Andre show maybe who knows
because I think that was the best garri
son I was so that's like that was like
my funny is I thought that was the
funniest bit on that first season
because you guys call out you're like
our first guest Jerry Seinfeld yeah and
his black dude comes out in like a white
pirates lounge Sam Sam I was waiting how
about happen cuz I was pretty good so I
would feel getting a tone of what the
show was I'm just
and this one I'm saying that over time
and I'm just genuinely at that point I'm
just working with a friend
yeah it's season one I look like this
man I can imagine you just looking like
what is going on you what is that this
is never gonna work not where comes like
I've said in multiple interviews is that
we take that [ __ ] in a bodega yeah in
Brooklyn you know and then a couple
years passed by and I would really just
forgot about it or you kind of forgot
about always jokingly say what happened
to that thing we take we're gonna be
famous or something so yeah yeah just
because that was a stage of my life
where I would tape anything with just
about anybody
now taped not a crazy amount of things
but a good amount and and stuffed and
pan out but it wasn't a big deal you
seem that you seem to always landing
them at the right places at the right
time
but that would like being his co-host
and then being in on broad city like
these these significant but not
significant roles that always land you
in the right place
well no being on a visit being in New
York I was in New York at the right
[ __ ] pocket man yes don't good it
wasn't right I was there at the right I
like you know the well how did you get
up with a lot Abbi and Ilana just from
being in New York around the same see
where I got the never doing stand-up or
I'm doing stand that we were just doing
you know so cases together I might have
met them at Parkside lounge or something
like that over mic sir showcase yeah but
uh Eric Andre I saw for the first time
at this spot Botanica Botanica bar he's
out his show on Sundays but it was just
being it and that's how I got on Fallon
was because um somebody got sick that's
right
and they hit me up the day before to do
the set and I was in town mama Chicago
I'm not getting that caught no you know
sense so I happen to be there I let that
to one because when that happened guy I
didn't talk I hadn't talked to you for a
couple months because you were like I'm
going to New York and I was like I'll
see you later and then all of a sudden
you were on TV I felt like you literally
hopped on the planes that I'm going to
Fallon that's what it's not like you
know they're like if I can I was like
all [ __ ] home he's on TV now yeah and
then from the Fallon [ __ ] they wanted me
to meet with Seth Meyers that's right
like directly after that right like the
week after yeah I met with semi and I
didn't want to take the meeting
why because cuz I didn't uh I was in my
mind I'm picking what's the meeting
about cuz I didn't I didn't submitted a
writing package to Saturday like what
you thought you use just getting sent to
the principal's office it's not a pretty
I thought I thought it was just a
[ __ ] meeting in they do general
meetings in Hollywood or in New York
yeah we talked well yeah we where they
just say a here's a list of people
you're going to be in town these days
here's a bunch of people go meet them
but you are doing were you doing general
meetings
Tendo I done a little bit maybe it was
2009 so I trying to think if I had done
a quick run of him in LA maybe not but
it was just actually you don't know how
what this all comes down to it all comes
down to Hannibal Burres just doesn't
give a [ __ ]
I give him fun obviously not you're like
yeah the meeting with Seth Meyers
I don't know how I want to take my a
fanatic honor you weren't even big [ __ ]
by that I wasn't but if I didn't know
what it was because I knew you have to
submit a packet or something to SNL that
was in my mind and so so you know so I
was coming back to Chicago that day on a
Priceline ticket a Priceline named your
flight ticket gotcha which if you're
familiar when you do that [ __ ] bid on
your own fly [ __ ]
yeah they're not easily changeable no
you miss that flight yourself on Tucker
Reed to change it and so I was not only
they said me what surprised at this time
I say my flight is at that exact time
and it is a Priceline name yo Jesus
Christ you told me the story and in my
everything is the price I name your own
price I don't think I can do this man
what does he want to talk in my agents
please go meet with him and I'm fine and
okay and I go meet with him and then uh
he offered me the job right on Saturday
life right and right in the room not
writing right away I guess the meeting
was a he wanted to gauge if I was crazy
enough
oh okay if I was like well obviously
somewhat crazy but and like workable
crazy is what make sure you didn't show
that what is Molly all [ __ ] up yeah I
guess that would let me just talk to
this guy for a little bit and we want
him to have in any offered me a job
when did he having lunch I don't worry
about money um then write that in that
meeting at the end of meetings okay so
did a little part of you still salty
about missing that flight no I got the
flight claims filed
I got it changed and
everything so late did you so right
after that did you just stay in New York
or did you still come back to Chicago
that night I had to fly back to Chicago
that night okay
and then I uh was hyped as [ __ ] on the
flight I remember telling the dude that
I was drinking on the flight I remember
telling do next to me I just got hired
to write this at night laughs yes until
I was so height and so then I did a set
at a got my rental car did it set at Big
Daddy's on I think on Irving Park Oh
announced to the crowd that's awesome I
got a set on I don't I got [ __ ] higher
Poseidon I love it was so hyped so
rewind he said you said it real quick
and passing but I right after that
interview you said and that was the last
time that I ever worried about money a
gift it's true on a percent legit like
never had to ever worry about paying
bills anything he just was like once I
started one somehow to get my Saturday
live checks and I said that was the last
time I worried about that mean that's
crazy the first few months yet 2009 it
was the first few months uh it took some
time getting my finances together
because before that I had some bad stuff
with banks from that initial trip that I
made to New York in 2006 just credit
card debts ensure no bro when I was in
New York the first time the trip that
everybody taught where I was sleeping on
the trains and anyway I went to my
sister's crib I was obnoxious I chopped
up didn't even tell I was coming to town
hey and I crashed her spot ended up put
me out there was one point and so I was
you know crashing with friends so-called
friends and quotes or crashing at
hostels you know hanging out with girls
aren't like that much crashed in a spot
but at one point I was will watch the
mutual bank and I did an empty envelope
deposit where you can just you have the
envelope you put in a [ __ ] you put it in
on the ATM deposit $1,000
yeah oh and I just decided let me just
try this yeah
to see and then you committed fraud I
committed fraud and so a brute oh yeah
but it shouldn't go through it shouldn't
tonight I'm Allie $9,000 at a time when
a thousand dollars was like a million
dollars to you so the first thing you
bought with that I probably went to the
bar right away to the bar got a spot got
a spot to sleep like I was like it was a
different I was like room service dog I
was getting the shrimp and so I mean
yeah I was living it eventually they
caught on that's a curse thing that
order if I get if I know that I don't
have to put my car down in a room yeah
just thing I do is that what are some
shrimp good that's my thing right away
shrimp cocktail right away should talk
to you and wine that's what I do
let's talk about look at we get back on
the side real quick let's talk about the
branding of shrimp shrimp okay
strip it good but they met that great it
would depend on the shrimp know that
you've been kind of I feel like shrimp
have really elevated in society that
good but it's never liro ch's yeah I got
you it don't taste like that like you
never really crave I do you crave oh
[ __ ] you're like ceviche shrimp [ __ ]
shrimp cocktail is like especially like
the Mexican style shrimp cocktail where
it's like in that red sauce [ __ ] I crave
the [ __ ] out of that that's like my
comfort food
i [ __ ] for shrimp a heavy bro really
like I think I don't think about shrimp
until shrimp is a nice room right so
shrimp is an option that's what I mean I
see shrimp on a menu oh oh I have some
shrimp and grits ooh I'll get some
shrimp but I've never seen you don't
share the passion and shrimp like
ideally you don't [ __ ] with oysters
either no do you come with that moister
I like certain types of voices but I
don't generally like oysters I never go
out boys if a spot I light up if I see
if I walk into a restaurant
and there's Oilers on ice I light up I'm
like oh [ __ ]
boy stur time for Tony trim make the
textures gross no it's like it's still
it's still got the ocean water in it so
depending on from what coasts is from
you getting to taste the water from
there that's a beautiful thing ah I
don't know man it says I respect them as
a food I ordered shrimp a lot I put
probably over the course of my life a
couple thousand dollars into the shrimp
business but it's not something I'm in
the six digits for shrimp you and six
dinners with shrimp I'm in six digits
[Music]
[Music]
what what a pip what attempts Issei uh I
eat so many scrimp
I got ID I'm pulling this he's all about
me yo you so mami
well alright hey dipwad go over there
nah Alberto fish our imaginary guest
Diplo
how does we shove it but I will play
with that she just pointed over there
like here is it ok I feel I see a dip
low I think at the block of this block
all day later but no that was a I liked
our little interview over here this was
great this was like a podcast this was
like my podcast and you were my guest
and I was asking if I felt it feels like
that a little bit yes thank you
ah festival times good man
first of all the time is my time my fest
I'm not to do this movie doc she's boss
in Atlanta when does it start Monday
Monday Monday so does that mean you're
going to be chillin on the oh there's
Diplo we chillin in Atlanta what's up
Diplo and you could sit right there
[Music]
get $30 off at 90 days apply up to baby
sister when you better get baby don't
come / aníbal Father's Day and around
corn and get a gift under time Father's
Day is around the corner
get a gift for your dad and dad that you
know on your husband oh boy Fred on
Sharon Lane
yeah yeah chart chart Buffett oh yeah
yeah yep go to get down with that Club /
have using talk space you can text audio
and video message your therapist as much
as you want your talk space therapist
will listen to you've it by work family
relationships you're terrible sports
team all of that stuff and you put you
on the path to a happier life to sign up
a learn more go to talk space calm slash
Hannibal and there's a special offer to
handsome rambling listeners you can use
coupon code Hannibal to get $30 off your
first month that's cold Hannibal by
visiting talk space.com slash Hannibal
talk space therapy why we live today
[Music]
that's your Mike Latta man doing art we
give in we got a little Thurman over
there feel free to play with his drum
machine - and they go through the you
can go to the propeller man I'm feeling
good yeah indigestion if it's you how
many times you talk about for -
indigestion it their arm it's like a
time ii pound wheels your last time here
mm long time with 2012 and you could
switch through the presets are you using
yeah that sounds smooth that sound
watery yeah I sounded like an acceptable
drip well you would yeah I see it
dripping but that's good sound funkiest
but oh that blown the drums Diplo you're
coming and get on the drum get it get it
wait to have one of these it's great
right try to FC 909 - yeah what's what
wait so I left my I saw you you're drunk
you are drunk
you're like standing like you know how
people get drunk and they just like
they're smiling but they're like the
wind blows them like left and right a
little tiny person
I just - on top of the stick it's like
looking into like the Boston skyline but
you before talking to you just did even
listen here's a mortal combat fatality
mode yeah and I walked away and I walked
back and you're still just doing the
same like one of those like with little
man up in there and looking hey yo wait
what this was in Boston before console
okay yeah
Major Lazer play Boston Colin fest yeah
and you you DJ the after-party at the
Harbor like Harvard lamp oh okay yeah I
missed I missed that one yeah it was it
was laughing so I was downstairs in the
main part which is very cheesy down then
I was probably like Harry Potter's uh
where they eat dinner or something yeah
and so it was very the vibe was weird
with some of the Harvard people you want
to stand on
tables with us and I want to stand on
the tables and then I just kind of
stepped out and started exploring the
space then somebody said you want to go
up to Diplo spot these DJ and I said
yeah and then I went up there and they
had all of the alcohol and we don't
drink they had all the up off that also
all of the good energy of Diplo and all
of the girls and so look at it it was
and then things got loose that's what
happens when you pour your drinks it get
yeah that's my house yeah this is really
a remote fest yet I never did know you
got to do it where is it it's in it used
to be a Nashville but now it's in Durham
okay and we just went yeah we just know
it in somewhere like South Carolina
though with some North Carolina yeah
that's where mogees from his Asheville
but then they moved it to Durham it was
like Electronic Music Festival just yes
festival but you nerd out with getting I
got like all kinds of new gear it's like
it's almost like a tech nerd kind of
convention where they show you all this
new [ __ ] video sound whatever yeah new
synthesizers they don't long times ago
North Carolina display on that one venue
and uh think it's a Nashville or the
orange peel yeah yeah oh it's bill yeah
this is about if the cars town as we're
not a college town I don't think I'm
sure they got one is more artsy it's
like a hippie town Artie you're all
towns is kind of live like yeah more
like it's more like F F F it's like real
organic I would say SF now not an SEC
Napa stupid like Athens yeah kind of
where you were you from Chicago okay
yeah I'm from Florida you go to serve on
Chicago they are playing this Spring
Awakening festival meal oh it's already
festival what's a [ __ ] role that I
like that is I just came fireworks oh
you two is shutting down the whole you
know we have it we can't play because
you to push us back by 40 minutes oh no
they like they stiffs they're flexing
yeah I'm not mad though are you same
thing cause you to you really you say
nobody else play yeah that'll do to I'm
that's the only one you two
yeah they said no one is allowed to play
40 minutes after them though the whole
during their set Oh gotcha no overlap at
all oh wow
I mean if they could force themselves on
your iPhone
I can't they do that I mean that's
actually Santosh it is more aggressive
so those routines you know that this
seems all talked alright if they could
just be on your phone why can't they do
this I'm so glad they're not on my new
phone it's all principle is this Tyler
to create it was really upset about that
I remember I was mad I'm one of those
Nokia phones again with a little screen
of the buttons it's battery lasts for
days yeah those are great
the wood Dom with the snake you feel so
addicted to your vote yeah I think this
I think when you're putting out a record
you want to like always have access
points like promote and do things like
that but you know that I'm just spent
time talking to people I don't want to
talk to ya you just say that because you
just feel the need to respond because
there's are endless amount of questions
and my phone for me and I just answered
them too honestly if I didn't have it we
don't want be asking anything yeah find
me other ways right yeah that seems like
a better way to deal with your
situations yeah at a time suck on jury I
mean it says you it's such a useful tool
you know cuz it's very useful if I was
food sex yeah and different information
in my life he was grabbing winning so
much news lately I never cared about the
news in this last two months has been
like I'm on the iPhone just like swiping
to the left on the breeding all the new
cuz the news is so crazy it's like a
reality show right yeah yeah insane I
keep can't stop I'm addicted to the news
every time you get a notice it's just
like what my how do you happen it's like
waiting for that watching something like
you know Bourne Identity movie or so
yeah the crazy [ __ ] going on so yeah
yeah but then part of me and I wanted
you to like this oh I stay up to date
too I was looking at this articles about
the call me yeah you know the come to
the FBI interview no and so then I'm
also the other is another side of me
when thinking do I even need to know
this [ __ ] well I think we you know I
thought he's gonna drop some more
bombshell dissecting some more crazy
[ __ ] like but at the same time yet but I
feel like we're all wanting things to
change if we want something crazy to
happen like we're waiting for like right
it's like a watch if we like driving
past a train wreck you know something
you know you're just looking at it and
you just you know it's you don't want to
do there's never
it's never any good news though right
been good news in a long time beauties
waiting for something good to happen
just from being an officer's crazy new
that sad news here and there yeah sighs
Philip say like you just waiting for
somebody to [ __ ] up majorly or to see
that one notices says United States
declares war on so until [ __ ] my
approach lately cuz before the election
when I thought it was a joke when he was
getting that close I had some Trump
talks in my set Oh somebody you
shouldn't be able to be President if you
what a subject of a Comedy Central Roast
and Trump's old and his dude is crazy
and then he got elected and I talked
about it maybe the day afterwards in
Kansas City and it was a different vibe
in the room and it late I don't I just
don't even it's not even I don't even
mention it just because I want my show
to be an escape from - yeah - polarizing
- like it's too weird it's it's like
everybody has an opinion on it no one
who seems to see eye to eye on anything
anymore
I think Villa I feel like the left has
just gotten to this point where we're
just like wishing it away yeah we're
like it's like don't even want to fight
this just please go away and think don't
seem to be changing anytime soon you
know no I mean this yeah his team is
strong i kow glad I came here to the
interview to drag the birdie down - well
it's okay with the bobbies we wanted
we're just with a we're now oh yeah yeah
all the Super's something a little open
bottom rule you know how we do that yep
yep yep
monitor what you want to weigh up same
exact get Romo Tony Canada
what'd ya say to the camera all over the
place here man easy yeah
do we have any more headphones one one
one three why it's not loud enough
wheelchair you're walking here to look
at wall so how do we have another um we
don't have enough Mike this baby is
bare-bones it won't do for play some
drunk Walt yeah go ahead
what was that it was vlog one one less
up hey - I respect yes love
hey if you are switched you can get down
if you want to if you want to answer on
the screen you could switch through the
kit whatever I can't I can't hit beat
them oh yeah that's right you gotta yeah
is this air you can use my place all
right
what oh oh
[Music]
oh yeah kind of well you go I'll see
them do you know this is actually pretty
accurate to what dance all to a dance
all ends right now
you know how about this how about I
don't really I have some reggae songs
that I like yeah but I don't don't get
it I don't get well I don't get really
like like going to a reggae spot is
gonna quit cuz I'm like I'm not seeing
that much range yeah
is it that much right it's not that much
is this a vibe it's just like it feel
like it's like a singular vibe with
different voices absolutely and to be
very honest with you I don't think they
actually want you to get it it's also
really linear culture like in the same
for a long time what get it is dope it's
dancing
I don't know maybe this lingo I'm not
done the right oh man is literally like
this is a using the same beats and then
they have ten I'll just jump on the same
beat yeah yeah you just got a either
like that where you talking about reggae
music every time I like dance Rawlings
all my things we talk well because dance
halls more like this you know like well
show ball and okay that in reggae music
would be like basically Bob Marley it to
like all right even like some white
regular you might hear already or
something I talked about the dance huh
yeah I think I'm a dancer
alright so dance i yeah it's pretty much
it's it's look great about the code I
was like insular think about this you go
to Chicago yeah if you don't understand
what a West Side percolator is versus a
South Side percolator you're just gonna
leave it alone and just know it's not
for you and you're gonna enjoy it when
it's time to enjoy there's somebody play
percolator you'll enjoy the one side
alright but it you might not get too
deep here's what I'll tell you honestly
I don't know the difference between an
website percolated Southside perk you
later
and I'm from the website
and I just don't have I learned I went
o'clock at my university so I had to
learn it you had to play it
yeah okay little Joey's pyramid is this
uh what time y'all on to name one song
man since you two done burgers what is
that - a class 5 a.m. because you like
to do what they want to do so we might
not even get to play tonight if you to
say you don't go on it's a it's what I
don't know we're going on 20 minutes 20
minutes as though I forgot to go poop so
yeah gotta get that out of here I did we
had to hit that national fried chicken
patties you got some hot ticket yeah did
you get the hottest one or the Prince
you got blogger super hot oh man
okay roll up did you so you you drank
what did you do to get over six bottles
of I've just been and I'm really sad are
not my cross-eyed right that was our
late yeah yeah yeah better carry me on
my shoulders like dragged me to the
grass done room the does the approach
you guys set change for a later time do
you or do you just go you go to stages
we have dancers so we can't really
straight too much from a formula because
otherwise we've done it before yeah I
like song so they're kind of danced away
yeah so yes it is kind of scripted up
with yeah there's a dance about 75% of
it has been same for them and then it
just kind of other times we just get
drunk and yeah just fall apart for the
24 units are the best ones that's what's
up yeah how much of those Harvey kids
for you damn I don't think they pay that
well but I got real high
only there with many other options it
was a Sunday night
it wasn't yeah I wanted a hover to in
the cafeteria no lie
do you know I met you you we met at UH
for the first time at it was a cypher
gas grill Accession I was in his house
it might have a Skrillex how they work
out how hungry hungry hungry hungry
hungry ham that's what I read you the
first time with ripio who I love Rufio
real feeling only every doing everything
he's everywhere I go he's in the band
that I met I go see ya
he's like in every rap group every band
every DJ and everything he's Ostler how
do you feel about Taylor Swift putting
out her all those that really happen so
I heard me right I don't really happen
to she dropped her she put all the stuff
on streaming the same day definitely
hates very draft I see that that's ice
cold
hahahaha raisi this business crazy that
is really iciest I've never heard of
that really happened I didn't see that
duffer I would I was Challen like it was
so it wasn't it wouldn't be something it
was normally did I'll be checking for
but it I saw that little statement
that's like a real like home people
don't notice this yeah because she made
such a big statement about pulling on
stuff from streaming a couple years ago
and to put it back on same day on the
same day what timing
mmm shake it off the look on your face
she was so genuinely like wait
absolutely happen it didn't happen I
don't feel but oh my that's really good
yeah yeah we will not do this how I feel
whole so like not great thing for
something like here I was pretty close
with the two girls of her um well let me
tell you like in a commercial continual
we did commercial TV we recently got all
our songs in the Baywatch commercial I
was like this can't be good cuz but you
know and it was actually kind of funny
yeah cuz I thought like it's going to be
really sucker but if I have to say no to
this and I was actually pretty funny
thanks Alton bring Walt usually they
watch you know that's why well you guys
drum solo man I appreciate you coming to
giving us a little bit of time we bout
to head over time for you and what you
go level country I'll see you on stage
hopefully Diplo party later
yeah we gonna come here I will come with
base number if I can get it do it we'll
do a little do the website percolator
I know I'm gonna go there I was going to
step with show me what can you Liam was
also my regulator are you a vital step
for what I'm Luke hey here we are at the
end of the show we're gonna tell
Bonnaroo we don't do with the dough
we're okay okay here we go
who's talking we go when there's time
for the percolator do it time for the
percolator just I'm gonna hurt you later
just I'm gonna hurt you later
just I'm gonna break you later right
you're a good dancer
country song okay go work you lay down
on the nest real time
[Music]